laval madame mois
madame ans elle vous êtes avec nous vous
avez toute mon attention
vous voyez seulement ici un tas de
chiffres et de paperasses ennuyeuse moi
j'y vois une histoire
et ça ne s'annonce pas bien
ça ne s'annonce pas bien du tout
qu'est ce qui se passe
je vis je ne suis pas ton mari je suis
une version de lui dans un autre univers
et je suis ici parce qu'on a besoin de
tout arrive et je suis très occupé
aujourd'hui j'ai pas le temps pour ses
bêtises
dans le multivers
j'ai vu des milliers d'effets linde
avant toi
accéder à leur mémoire leur émotion
et même leurs aptitudes
une puissante force maléfique a commencé
à propager le chaos à travers le
multivers c'est eve lyne n'est pas ma
tante et
il se pourrait bien que ce soit notre
seule chance de sortir d'ici en vie nos
victoires je suis très nul evelyne du
mans
or maman se défend bien
m
l'univers
[Musique]
est tellement plus vaste que tu le veux
moi
[Musique]
je pourrais être n'importe où
je veux quand même mettre ici avec toi
gare ne peut être plus important que la
destinée plus qu absolument chaque monde
qui composent notre multivers un filet
il n'y a aucune chance que ce soit moi
les bling que vous essayez de trouver
toutes les injustices que tu as vécu 17
/
jusqu'ici
à ce moment brescia
ne laissez rien te distraire s'il te
plaît
[Musique]